Tilman
question no sorry J BT we can't I was
going to say welcome back P lat
oh he's back we were able to hear you oh
oh he broke it he broke that again
[Music]
now
you
there we go can y'all hear me
trying to figure out YouTube streaming
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
let me meet the
how do you actually get the live link to
the to the stream like I don't see it on
the stream now page like did you use get
it because you got notified or something
or what
need an easier way to show sort of like
the discord chat and then I've got the
actual chat in from the livestream not
really sure how to watch them all
although certainly war against yoga
thank you we're just pulling Daniel to
the Illuminati meeting oops that's not
Daniel
Daniel either yeah I mean I can but it's
gonna reverb back into the stream I
don't know if I should put I don't how
I'm supposed to talk to you and then not
have it echo wait went a second okay I'm
not sure how I can hear you
it's allowed I can certainly hear you on
a discard I think that will be better
for us
so I guess I could turn off I have no
idea I don't know how to so I just don't
know how to talk to you and not take
because I cannot pass desktop audio
through so I could just pass just the
mic through I think that probably makes
the most sense because my speakers are
right by the microphone
and I shoot it twice well yes you just
need to meet the street yeah that's what
what they did you pay and you don't
still hear me twice as long as you meet
it or what they say or I could sing you
you're not hearing it twice if you meet
the stream right yeah I can see yeah
yeah I can hear you just too hot now
it's a big laugh on youtube so if you
want to talk we need to I need to hear
you at this work I have no idea how you
sound on like coming through what if I
need to up the berry - that looks pretty
bad at least from what I'm seeing
is everybody everybody's bit rate look
at that bad like mine looks horrible
yeah
compression kills huh yes you should
I'm not sure if it's a youtuber might be
obvious this bitrate was acceptable for
streaming like GTA but that was too
twitch I just wonder if there but
there's also like 50 compression choices
that you can make I'm looking at it now
so at least someone says 6000 bitrate at
least back with the GTA stream that was
like that would be way too much like
2500 to 3000 was what I did then
bringing me what's the stream about well
right now we're just trying to set
things up and then once that gets set up
we're gonna start messing around the arm
see if we can't make it a little better
I don't know if I can I'm not sure if I
can change the bitrate as I'm streaming
I'm not sure if I'm up to like cut it
and start again
what I can say is that your voice wake
viewer on YouTube stand and discard any
cash that what your voice sounds better
on YouTube than on this birth to a
clearer
well my mic isn't really close right now
that's probably it
oh it's a different mic oh is it it
could be a different mic sometimes it
picks up the stupid microphone on my
webcam oh it's a different mic
oh is it it could be a different no I
just listen to it's definitely the same
mic it's probably cuz it's just further
away or something
I'm pretty sure I can change that live
at least it went up in OBS let's see how
that looks
still it's pretty grainy
so that's a 5,000 bit rate play I don't
know if it sits there for a while it
starts to clear up
say something Daniel I'm telling thing
one two three
everyone's complaining your voice isn't
this this this this this this it's still
blurry though like people are saying it
was my background that was causing it
but it still looks super blurry to me I
mean I guess it sort of clears up I
don't know
mine just got super clear now it's it's
way better way but like maybe tried to
scroll yeah I'm already doing it we
could just take for certain I think
there's still like an eight second delay
here yeah please a big delay yes when I
said roll it was like it takes forever
to get back clear again I know it looks
- looks ok for me no even when i
scrolled yeah like when i scrolled
around it went back to being pretty much
not legible I mean it's way better so
not bad when when you're scrolling not
like on my last tutorial video tutorial
oh oh you your background yeah so it was
causing some problems in the background
might be just too much but yeah even if
I scroll around it seemed to go away
hmm
nope
so now I got to figure out four summers
into whenever I have like multiple
cameras and stuff and especially if OBS
is trying to access this camera I won't
be able to get the armed camera says
xsplit has got it okay
you
no OpenCV is not deep learning
hell no I mean it's not that far I'm
he's not that much different just a
bunch of using math simple mathematics
to do stuff
and you're gonna cut some Zach bucks
so I can't figure out why it thinks that
xsplit has that camera
oh you're waiting coz I have no idea
what I'm doing so
okay there we go so now I have at least
that camera on but it's like super blue
because this other camera is adjusted
for this I'm not really sure I'm gonna
fix that either unless we create new
values for the for the red you guys not
gonna get detected
see
I mean we can try I think probably the
best thing otherwise because I can't
really edit both like you can't edit
these two cameras the like the white
balance you can't really edit them
separately this is an exact same camera
so we can that guess filter specifically
for this blue doubt photo oh actually
here this will help
I mean it's it definitely is picking up
the puck just a little extra there yeah
but if we just
yeah so we might actually get away with
that despite being super dim
so the problem with the lamp is I don't
really think that's gonna like that
probably wouldn't be evenly lit unless
the lamp was like way over otherwise
gonna be super bright in the middle
unless you put like a maybe like a shop
light or something but I feel like
that's detecting it pretty well
or maybe it was my fault
No
I think the board transparent and poke a
lot of holes I'm not quite sure how you
would do that by like a piece of
plexiglass or something maybe I'm not
sure
so the problem for sure is like there's
a shadow on that like right here I'm not
quite sure I guess it's the camera above
it on the piece of wood yeah only works
in the sim
we really need a way I might have to
change just change the white balance of
the camera let me try
yeah I just don't so it's like we're
storming here right now so there's like
no outside light I do have a light on in
my room but for some reason it just
looks like the camera just looks super
dim over there and you can modify the
like the keep what the look how much
light the camera brings in and all that
stuff but for some reason that doesn't
seem to be helping and I think it's cuz
there's two cameras so it modifies one
camera but not the other one for some
reason yeah I mean that's basically what
I'm trying to do Nebula I just doesn't
seem to be taking effect for some reason
okay
so forget all the spots that we couldn't
actually see it I'm able to mess with
the settings now at least we tried
so pry need to fix that threshold but I
just want to see for some reason when
the puck went up to like the top left
and
but well the bottomleft actually doesn't
really have much of uh I mean I there's
like the shadow from like the bar of the
stand that's I mean I see those but the
pucks not really fully in there so I'm
not really sure why that would be
causing that there
so with turn off I don't think that's
gonna help
turn it off and on again that might help
actually that's why I hadn't to do the
camera and believe it or not so
sometimes it does work
see if that's good enough
that looks about right
what we really need is like a way to I
wish you could just like color pick or
something and OpenCV and it would just
pick the range for you that would be
nice
how to get into open source projects go
to github.com and start taking part
okay so now I actually changed so before
we were using like the little suction
thing I don't know where it is
anyway reason that to grab the actual
striker but that kind of got problematic
because for some reason it would get
tilted up or down or whatever and then
eventually it would get lifted off the
board and the puck would just go right
underneath it so I changed a little
gripper thing so now we got to fix that
and get that's actually hit this but
somebody and actually hit off of the box
so I got to set that back up but at
least we have the puck now you save that
maude sky let's see I'm pretty sure
Scott is a mod on the in the comment
section but it doesn't look I don't know
if he isn't here
okay here we go
how many monitors four and then probably
a fifth if I connect the other computer
but right now it's just just my main PC
is connected right now the part of the
problem though is I think so the arm
connects to the PC via just like USB and
so using basically one camera a
microphone another camera and the arm I
think is causing like USB bandwidth
issues so probably gonna end up having
to use another computer is my guess it's
just a little too much
ARM based on Arduino no they're like you
can use an Arduino with it or like a
Raspberry Pi but I don't even know like
I know it's just like a totally custom
custom arm
the neural network that the GTA
self-driving car used
oh just that well I'm not really sure
the do toriel covered quite a few there
was the object detection and there's
also an inception model that we used the
arm doesn't use an Arduino like it comes
with an Arduino like if you want to do
like that open mV camera for example
you're going to connect that through an
Arduino but the arm itself isn't
actually like a Arduino based as far as
I know
it would probably help if I plugged in
the arms
use a PCI card four more USB bandwidth
I honestly done on the answer to that I
didn't even know there was such a thing
as USB bandwidth until I started running
out of it I'll mute myself from discord
am i muted or have i meeting you already
timeout Daniel I don't have discord
muted
okay so I I can hear you on this court
and we can't really talk with such a big
delay on YouTube oh yeah I mean if I'm
going to talk directly to you I can just
use push-to-talk and then everybody can
hear and you can hear immediately just
as long as you don't have the stream on
sound I'm just trying to get everything
connected at this point
the Swift armies is Arduino mega 2560
news to me man I didn't know I get comes
with an arm do we know that you can hook
up to it I didn't think it actually was
built are you sure it uses that like it
was built with the 2560
oh why windows I feel like I've answered
that question like I'm bajillion times
so where's my ROI window you guys shut
this door
so I use Windows just simply because
like Windows to me is a better user
operating system as opposed to like
Linux is great for development and stuff
but if you're going to be doing any sort
of video editing even like recording OBS
sort of works on Linux but not very well
it doesn't do like multiple monitors
well and then I don't even know what you
would use to edit if you needed to edit
and then if you do anything else besides
development like Linux just is not the
best in my opinion like especially if
you're gonna play like any games or like
a lot of desktop apps that kind of stuff
just don't work as well on on Linux
Mac's pretty good I just I think Mac's a
good kind of in-between the problem with
Mac is you just can't really build Mac
so you're gonna pay a ton of money to
have a Macintosh like PC or not a
Macintosh like an Apple PC
so right now the arm is just way too
high I'm not really sure I don't think
you can actually see so this is the raw
feed unfortunately you can only see like
just the base the arm so he's trying to
hit that puck but he doesn't have a
striker and he's way too high but anyway
that's working pretty well
may want to change the stream title I'm
pretty sure just a syntax live stream am
I wrong
dual-boot is the best yeah so I do dual
boot into Linux but I don't really use
it too often to be honest I used it in
it like the original reason I put it
into alright dual booted Linux was for
like deep learning with tensorflow
because it just didn't really support
Windows very well initially but since at
least a year or something I mean it's
been fully supported on Windows like I
just have no reason like Windows is fine
I mean Windows doesn't do well is like I
guess some development stuff and like
putting like packages on Python is a
pain in the butt that kind of stuff but
even then like once you get used to it
it doesn't really it doesn't like slow
you down I don't think
so I'm pretty sure these are like
millimeters so this would be like 83
millimeters high which looks about right
and I need it to be I don't know maybe
like 20 I'm gonna set this to 320 and
then like once it grips the puck for
some reason and like a lot of times when
it actually closes down on the puck it
lifts it slightly in the turn of the
puck the striker and so in the strikers
up a few millimeters or whatever
sometimes the puck especially after
playing for a little bit just slides
right underneath it so you grab it and
then you're gonna move down a little bit
anyway let me see if that looks about
right
oh we need to take that ROI so we don't
have to calculate that every time
I don't think dual-boot makes a problem
for a hard drive in the long run its
effort like running out of space if you
just got partitioned out but I can't
imagine why a dual boot would negatively
impact the drive
so I'm only gonna grab that region of
interest like one time so I don't really
see a point in doing every time unless
that camera moves but I've bumped it so
many times it's just it's just like
hanging off a piece of wood right now is
every time I go over there or whatever
and there's like a cord that strings all
the way over there so I'd knock it off a
bunch but hopefully this will be fine at
least for the stream speeding up cv2 is
cpython
I sure mana I'm pretty sure cv2 is
already pretty well optimized I can't
imagine that there'd be much more flat
to go like I think a lot at seat OpenCV
is seed and I'm assuming you mean scythe
on Nazi Python because cpython is what
we're using right now I guess I'm not
sure if this just never closed or what
so even at 20 that looks pretty high
let's try me see what zero looks like I
suppose five and two
risk you can use the robot operating
system yeah with with the arm I honest
I've I think I've used the robot
operating system one time so I don't
know much about it but I haven't done it
with the arm but yeah the arm does
support that go away how can I search in
a video for keywords I have no idea what
you're asking
I might have to like lower the arm right
now I have that like on a box that I'm
also using the box to block the goal I
only have two minutes like it's not
gonna go into the negatives I don't
think let's see if it does I don't think
it does if you turn the arm off it will
go down but I think that went down any
further
do I get tired of standing no not really
I mean we could give them the the
striker and see how he does but right
now the gripper is like too far above
the thing I think it'll grab it but I'm
not sure how well the cargoes are back
to mine I'm not in cargo shorts there's
no there are side pockets here unless
you think all like beige shorts or cargo
shorts you're mistaken sir this isn't
quite the same place as Episode four I
don't think because we didn't talk about
like for example or is it yeah like this
stuff so the arm was moving just way too
slow but you can send these commands and
like what this does is it changes the
acceleration of the motors in the arms
this is just like your G code that we're
just saying straight to the arm and
anyway so you can make the arm actually
go a lot faster but then it's like to do
like the strike we set the acceleration
to be something absurd like they say the
highest number you should use is like
300 and same thing with speed they say
the highest number you probably use like
30,000 so we're using 5,000 and a
million you can do it for like really
short bursts but if you if you just
always have the arm going at like a
5,000 acceleration and a million meters
a million millimeters per second the
motors like freeze up and get real
jittery it's weird I'm not really sure
why they're doing that
super glue I'm not sure who you're
responding to there Mick time unless you
mean literally super gluing it to the
arm I don't think I want to do that I
could superglue something to the arm
though that would be doable but
otherwise no don't think it's good yeah
g-code flake
I don't know what the rules are on
YouTube with streaming songs I know at
least on Twitch you can pretty much get
away with anything except for it'll get
muted in the playback later I think
that'd be good enough to actually grip
the things so I'll see if that works
oh she's gotta reset it to a good spot
yeah don't on YouTube yeah I wouldn't
expect that that'd be is acceptable on
YouTube
mmm
so the number is sitting the arm for
some reason it's holding that position
and I'm not really sure why cuz the Y
should be the left and right X's forward
and back yeah I'm not really sure the
arm doesn't seem to want to reset to
center which is on its throne and fit
over there or maybe oh I see what's
going on
so actually probably what we should do
is this this
I don't know if y'all can you actually
hear that arm but that's the arm
freaking out over there
mm-hmm okay so that one definitely works
Oh
and now I'm not sure why this through
this error
almost so you got nothing from the image
for some reason from the camera hope
that didn't just die on us
it's lost the [ __ ] or this trekker
immediately that's frustrating
let me try again
okay now it's like in the center of the
thing so hopefully it'll be fine so
sometimes one of the things I'm having a
hard time doing is like right now things
are just like frozen like it's just not
doing anything and then they like
finally wakes back up and he's just
trying to get in front of that puck oh
my gosh see again so I'm not really sure
what's causing this is probably the most
frustrating part of it all and it froze
again for the hit like the arm is living
its own life yeah see I'm be like I
definitely think we have like a USB
bandwidth issue because like it's
happening way more frequently at least
it hit it that time it's happening way
more frequently now that I'm using both
cameras
and I feel like the speed of the strike
for some reason is actually much slow
like it should actually be quite a bit
faster than that is the camera lagging
behind the buffer yeah I built those
wrong they're not very good I promise
so this one has to the board is meant to
be like diagonal and I just like screwed
it on to a piece of wood to make it work
yeah this is my favorite one though this
one's like super fast
yeah it's almost like it's just striking
unbelievably slow and it shouldn't be it
should be modifying right here to make
that strike like usually that strike is
[Music]
like you shouldn't even be able to see
it move on camera like it's it's super
fast if it works right I wonder if it's
pressing down too hard so the old
version could only hit the puck that
like that hard but I'm wondering if
maybe maybe we shouldn't I don't think
it's actually going into the negatives
but that could cause the problem if it
is but I don't think it is just do this
and then I'm gonna move this back to
here so hopefully I'm going to reset we
don't have to worry about the gripper
needing to go back
can the armed mine Bitcoin I don't think
so
Oh see you can definitely tell the arm
definitely the arms moved itself
let's see now I don't know if you can
tell but the puck will go right
underneath it because it like lifts it
up just slightly so we definitely need
to lower it a little bit what we did
let's do mmm
hmm as it moves to the center so it set
the gripper to true move to Center and
actually raised up
which is weird because the Z should be
up and down and if anything so it set
the gripper to true and then moved I
wonder if I should not what happens if I
just don't modify it at all
yeah dr. Smith it's probably the hardest
thing right now is getting it to just
stay stay pressed down always keeping
this putt from getting stuck
and it froze again
lose something as a bridge so the the
problem is not really like if you glue
it then it's just gonna hold still like
it's still gonna plausibly lift above
lift over the puck
I also don't know if we would I'm not
sure how to stop it from freezing like
it does now it seems to freeze when you
move the puck real fast I think it just
freezes whenever it anything happens
real fast to be honest a lot of times
like after a strike for example it'll do
that but I'm not really sure how we can
make that better we could change the
acceleration and then you could also
change like so right now the arm is
theoretically processing as fast as it
can because we're just going through
this let's see here just while true so
we could like stuff in like a little
sleep and maybe that would make things
better I'm not really sure because
obviously at some point it's just
getting overloaded
no I don't know if the webcam framerate
would be enough right now the at least
you know like that's probably something
that'll come up as we continue on but
like right now probably the biggest
thing like for example like it hasn't
frozen at all this whole time it's been
trying to just set up for this puck is
if it was moving and it hasn't frozen at
all so I'm a little curious why it
freezes when it's making bigger
movements I'm just not sure what's
causing that you don't think it's a USB
your face camera doesn't freeze honestly
don't know enough about USB bandwidth
but usually in the past it's been my
microphone actually it'll like start
making weird noises but it I'm not
really sure like what how how the
computer gives things priority
necessarily or if it would just degrade
everything so instead of adding weight
to overload the motors I wonder if you
just added weight to the puck or just
like added some weight at the end of the
arm just to always keep it pressing down
but the arm will press down the problem
is it doesn't seem to plug if you set
the arm to be zero right the Z of zero
millimeters as it swivels to the left
and right you can actually see it
changes its height just slightly which
is too much for this puck I mean the
robot can't you could definitely use
OpenCV to Detective pucks velocity
though same thing is what was being
discussed before like using motion
blurring and stuff like that you could
use the blur to attempt to figure out
how fast it was going or just you know
between frames how how many pixels has
the puck moved or something like that to
detect this view
yeah it still wants to make that strike
unbelievably slowly and I'm wondering if
it's because I'm using my other camera
too because before it would make that I
don't know how to express it in words
but it was a violent strike
so I get least in that case after the
strike for sure like maybe I need to
change this and settle it down slightly
so I think yeah froze again there
he just scored on himself
ohmygosh puck am i causing the freezes I
don't know how I would be causing them
embarrassin
it freezes when it doesn't detect the
puck and sends a weird instruction I
can't really tell if the puck is
disappearing when I go over there I mean
that's possible
that actually would be really nice bring
like an air compressor in here armed
constantly vibrates because this is like
constantly adjusting to where it thinks
the puck is
I'm tempted to just slow this thing slow
this down it's like a slight sleep
possibly I said help it be the answer I
guess if it doesn't find a pot calm
why is that puck that puck is just not
moving very well I think there's I think
I have a different another one or maybe
I should flip it over
of course it's frozen again maybe when I
get close to it it just freezes I don't
know source code on github yeah it is
you can get hub home slash cindex slash
you arm yeah this one's definitely
moving a little better that sleep is not
doing us any favors but okay I don't
know why it keeps moving that way to
needs to hit the puck
so at least with that sleep I'm gonna
try to make the sleep smaller but at
least with that sleep it's definitely
hitting it unfortunately that also makes
the camera feed lag every 0.2 seconds or
whatever but now it's hitting the puck
consistently oh my gosh we made it three
quarters of the table with that hit
that's a good one
fail I just froze that was too much for
it it might be the case to that maybe so
at least the desired wise a legitimate
like if you send illegitimate
coordinates or something like that to it
that kind of makes the arm pretty angry
I don't know if the videos are set to
just automatically be accessible offline
or not this would be at least the first
while I might need to trim up the first
while of the stream for when we were
setting it up I'm gonna make this sleep
a little shorter now let's do one well
that at least it seems to be freezing a
whole lot less
I was really hoping it would start
before that puck comes back go
so now I'm thinking hmm I can't bring up
the there we go
so I made this leap at least a little
smaller that seems to be going pretty
well it's still striking like
unbelievably slow it shouldn't be going
that slow I'm not really sure why oh if
only it had it a little harder that
would have been the score when you issue
a move command it could go either way
Lucas you can make the move commands
either async or synchronous just remove
the freezes well the freezes are what's
actually helping the code continue to
run right now it seems like it really
wants some sort of delay I just have the
freeze for now but we'll see
Daniel if you want to thread it you can
make an example of that if you want I
can't decide if it I think it just for
yeah okay yeah whenever this starts my
blossom out maybe it is I wish I and he
did yes so for some reason when I'm like
pulling up the screens they're just like
not showing but there's the other one so
I do think maybe there's something to it
if there is no puck on the screen well
we're not throwing any airs which is
what's weird to me but again it's frozen
on this one I mean there's at least some
red there so I'm not quite sure why that
would be something I can't calculate
okay it's just going don't need no
stinkin neural networks who needs them
do you have no literally all this is
doing is just figuring out where the
like basically the Y position of the
puck is and it just attempts to match it
and then if the puck goes to like beyond
a specific x position it goes to strike
at the puck and like that's it that's
all it's doing you just went over that
again
oh that's very frustrating
okay I'm gonna lower lower the asleep I
think Lucas the async could be a problem
except for two things one is I don't
actually think let's see whoa that arm
just freaked out so actually these
commands are all asynchronous commands
but at least via their documentation the
Swift flush command is waiting for all
the sink
asynchronous commands to complete so it
shouldn't be a problem but they're there
api's been problematic before for me as
I've been messing with it so that could
be the problem but I don't think so
CPU usage that's a good question
that's a good question let me see
I'm gonna go ahead and guess it's
probably not CPU RAM related but maybe I
don't think so though unless it suddenly
spikes up
is that puck too high again see that's
very frustrating I feel like the arm
slowly starts raising up yes so this is
a good one so definitely there is no
puck up in here so there's probably
something to that
someone help me I must be blind its
profits got to be somewhere in here it's
just weird because we're not there's no
error that's being thrown so I feel like
that's not necessarily an issue maybe if
we
we could just grab a length of any of
these X's wise whatever's and if it's
not long enough like if we don't have
enough red pixels we should probably
just pass and not do anything with the
arm I think that's probably what I'm
just going to do we're
1300 for the you arm is it really at
least the last time I looked at their
website it was 754 the arm not 1,300
that's probably soon as I really
released the video they raised the
prices
yeah it's not
I'm not sure where you're seeing 1300
but yeah I mean obviously the knocked
out price I'm not sure the arms ever
been 1300 for real 750 yeah 749 and then
like you can buy like each of little
pieces honestly if you do like for laser
engraving and 3d printing like you went
into a 3d print something really small
I'm not confident the arm would be good
enough especially like unless I can't
figure out why the X like the height
doesn't seem to be working right like it
does seem to slowly be creeping up which
would be a massive issue for a 3d
printing but the laser engraver is
actually pretty cool like I've made a
couple signs and stuff with it it takes
a while like if you want to get a nice
deep engraving but I did like probably
20 something plus passes and it was
super accurate like I've never messed up
or anything some sort of spring on the
arm that would be really nice is anybody
1,300 with the accessories I'm not
really sure what all except like me if
you got all the accessories I'm not even
sure even with all the accessories it
would be 1,300 but maybe I just can't
Matt but good try to buy a laser
engraver and a 3d printer for I don't
know 900 bucks or whatever it would be
all together
salut so I have no idea how to do like a
sprint like how would you incorporate a
spring on the grip part so it was always
pressing down unless you gripped the
thing that had a spring on the other
side of it that pressed down other than
that
I'm not really sure how you would set
that up
so maybe when we go to calculate the the
X&Y average and then calculate the Y
position like all these things I can't
imagine you'd be able to do these
calculations though with Nan's like if
it was empty but I wonder if somewhere
along the lines were passing like an a
non numerical figure to the arm and like
that's what's causing the whole problem
of freezing
it like I can understand so nebula with
the stepper motors Yi I don't know I
thought we were resetting hold on let me
see I got rid of the X's at one point or
I'm sorry this Z yeah
so so I wonder if if that's right we
should be able to I'm lost in my own
code where's the gripper oh right here
so XY we said Z should be probably well
we'll start with a three we can end with
a zero or actually let's do a start with
a five end with a two and what we could
do is we could always pass a Z equals
two or something like that so if it
could go back to where it started
so the sleep in the loop actually did
work I mean it seemed to help a lot
actually
so there's like two scenarios where it
seemed like the arm was freezing one was
when it actually went to making a strike
I would say like half the time until
harm would freeze and then the other
half of the time was apparently when the
puck would just disappear I just didn't
really notice that because I wasn't
staring at it I was moving the puck but
my shadow was hiding the puck and so
we're wondering if that's the issue
there so I think what I want to do so XY
so every time we set the position let's
set the Z to be 2 so hopefully that'll
hold if that's true that the stepper
motor was just slipping or something
like that
hopefully we can just keep resetting it
back to 2 and that will be good enough
we'll see so let me add that sleep back
in I got rid of it when I was doing the
controls ease
[Music]
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna try that
for now Commons after Z parameters do I
not I must be reading that a little late
but I'm pretty sure we have them nope
thank you
okay let's see how that works then are
you being serious Technovation
so so 808 the conversion is basically
like we know I thought I wrote it down
oh yeah I did
so like the arms maximum coordinate
let's say is it goes from positive 220
to a negative 220 so then you take the
pucks location on the screen after the
region of interest and you calculate
where it is in the you know Y location
like percentage-wise and then you apply
that percentage to the arms min and Max
and then that's how we're normalizing it
and then we're just setting it to the
exact same percentage setting so that's
it let's try to run that again I mean it
is there you just can't really see it
it definitely lifted up I can even I can
see it's like floating in the air right
now why did it lift back up and I don't
know if it's frozen let's see yeah so we
are only moving the arm if a puck can be
located
[Music]
so right here if the Len of our exes so
that's if it can find more than five
pixels that are red then we're willing
to try to move the arm so I'm not really
sure why it would freeze at this point
because we're still will this guy gave
us some time out I don't think we've
always seen the time out have we
oh you guys can't even see that right
now it definitely threw a timeout but
not here
there's no time out there unless I can't
see the puck but I think that's true
so Oh jerk no take me back to there so
this time doubt on the command for
setting us back here for some reason
that command timed out and I'm not
really sure why that would happen
[Music]
I think I can send only think you're
because we if we send it I think that
that could be what's causing the the
problem but I don't really think we want
to send it necessarily asynchronously I
don't know that's gonna be a good idea
either
I'm gonna try that because clearly at
least to start we got a timeout here but
then it froze again and it didn't say
that same thing
so I thought about circle detection in
the problem is it's gonna also detect
the puck probably already frozen and I'm
pretty confident yeah see like there was
definitely a puck and it's already
frozen and it's frozen again like gosh
but I think I'm gonna change back to the
synchronous commands then it's getting
angry over there
best GUI in Python yeah definitely pie
cutie but I'd seriously reconsider why
you're making a desktop-based you know
application these days I wonder it am I
not am i setting that xia na's equals to
i feel like that's not really helping
she's back above that Puck pot slightly
at least there and another time out and
let me pull up the puck though so
definitely again another time out
but the puck was definitely visible in
that
print everywhere to see where it's
getting stuck if you want to add some
prints to the code feel free in fact I
can put this up on github right now and
if you have an idea for what would help
I'll gladly see it
that's a good hit at least gotta have
one
at least there he the arm got stuck on
the side pressing way too hard so I'm
wondering I think I could so two twenty
is the legitimate min and Max for the
arm but I wonder if yeah that's the
ghetto repo but that doesn't have this
exact code in it so let me let me update
that and then I'm also I think it would
be wise to change the min and Max cuz
when it was pressing against the wall it
was not happy about doing it
yes for like companies that want desktop
applications still I mean sure I'm I'm
sure lots of people want them but if
you're just trying to make something for
yourself or whatever I would consider
not using desktop apps anymore
yeah it also definitely seems to be like
when the puck moves really fast but I
doesn't really make much sense to me you
can definitely issue commands to like
vastly different coordinates to the arm
and that's like totally acceptable so
I'm not really sure why that would be
causing trouble either
what would I recommend is to the desktop
apps like Web Apps and then it's like
you can still have a web app that
doesn't connect to the outside world
like you don't have to make it publicly
accessible it's just you have so many
more options there like then you would
with like a local desktop application in
my opinion I also just hate building any
like anything with in like you eyes with
Python is just not enjoyable it's not a
good experience overall and then even
with qt like especially it was
especially if you're making something
like commercial and stuff the licensing
for pi QT is not ideal
rapid commands will the issues like
we're not issuing rapid commands anymore
we've got the sleep in here so that's
not really I can't really be it and it
was doing even better with like a point
to sleep but okay yeah that's exactly
what I'm doing I'm programming this to
drive in Grand Theft Auto 5
okay what
honestly don't know I think that's the
camera probably just trying to apply
something on the camera that doesn't
exist possible I don't know
interesting let me upload this code real
quick to github
alright there's the code on github
someone wants to try two issues put in
some like debug commands or something
they think could run better let me know
I'll try it out so I think I'm also
gonna you can't really change this too
much because otherwise it's never it's
not gonna line up with the puck
correctly but it was definitely slamming
itself against the wall which was not
really an ideal circumstance go
now it's freezing a lot
so as weird as like if as the puck moves
that's when it likes to freeze but when
it gets all stuck up in the corners like
this no problem no problem at all look
until I go over there and move the puck
and then it freezes again
can the camera record at a lower quality
you mean the camera for the stucco good
for the arm we could try that so I could
change the rescale factor so it's not as
large of an image
that does not seem happy to me I'm not
really sure how come that guy trend so
badly down to a 10 by 10 I don't think
that's gonna go very well how does it Oh
we'd have to read that's our problem
okay
I was wondering why I got so trimmed up
we need to if we're going to do that we
have to recalculate our region
a web application tutorial yeah I've got
flask and Jenga I'm I do tornado at some
point what I don't know
I don't understand why I would trim it
that much I know
could you put a camera on the arm yeah
yeah it does have a camera that you
could put on board and then everything
would be like more relative
I just thought an overhead camera would
more likely be like easier
no new tutorials on blockchain
development
oh this is like hanging
how often do i stream like this I've
been streaming like this every day for
ten years
what
I don't know if I got the ROI maybe
outside of the range I don't know how
that would happen unless it got rounded
up maybe I'm not sure
I don't nobody told me to comment these
out
Krypto I was definitely lying this would
be the first time I've ever streamed on
YouTube so thank you for the donation
Antonio once tucks them
here we go
and lisp tutorials
so Antonio why would you give me an
example why you would use
multi-threading in Python versus
multi-processing and Python at least for
me like threading and Python seems kind
of pointless
I don't know why it keeps like it's
acting like it's not taking anything
from that camera
other than that camera maybe not being
on or something I can't imagine why it
says it has an untyped there no that's
definitely working where's our book it's
music so like reading on it just doesn't
seem to make much sense to me to thread
on Python but like threading on say or
multi-processing on Python makes a whole
lot of sense more lighting now that's
just too slow honestly changing the
resolution only seems to be causing
trouble so I'm gonna go back to the
initial numbers let's see if I can just
control Z my way out of this
I think I'll keep the 210 now let's see
that a bit
can you give me an example though of
like when would you need to do when
would you be sharing data in between
thread inside one of your processes I
just honestly have never come up against
that kind of a problem or I would just
use async IO or a sync EO as the
profession is caught
let's come right under it uh that's very
very frustrating download more ram
that's honestly usually my solution on
like servers you can either make your
code more efficient oranges by bitter
server
so at least so maybe when it makes the
strike it gets kind of off place but
every time we move the arm we're trying
to reset it back to that Z coordinate so
I'm still a little confused on like why
why why that puck keeps lifting up
it's like as it moves like to the center
it uh so I'm gonna reset it right here
as I like blues of the center it lifts
up this is really frustrating
I'm trying to think if it could be like
so it's sitting on a box still shouldn't
be lifting up though
and frozen lovely sell merch I have some
shirts and hoodies they're still in bags
though I moved I closed the shop
whenever I moved can you let the striker
sit loose it's possible I've not seen
how you can do that you can only set the
gripper to be like true or false so
either is like max grip or no grip
so like at least in this case like yeah
you know you're saying that maybe that
like threading would help this I'm not
I'm not confident like threading could
help maybe retain the camera feed
although so in a multi-process but but
other than that what's actually causing
the arm to hang or what's actually
causing something here to hang is it's
something that has to be resolved I I'm
not really sure that threading is gonna
solve this one
and we still need some way to keep this
gripper or the
I just can't think what what's causing
it to like lift up and why setting it
back down is changing anything set the
process to fry hurt don't think that's
gonna help
I was lifting in the code have it
dropped Andrey grabbed the puck so the
problem with that is like to drop it and
regrab it takes a decent amount of time
it'd be better if it just didn't lift up
Franklin we don't really know why it's
lifting up
so it sits on a box but and so I was
thinking maybe the box was on level but
even like right now like as when it
moved and actually rotated into the
center that's when it lifted up so then
I thought oh well when it goes to the
edge and will go back down possibly but
it's not so it's not like the arm is
like tilted or something like that on
the box I think it's just lifting up but
every loop or every time I'm actually
asking the arm to move I'm telling it to
go back to you know a zero position and
it's not doing that either so I'm not
well a 1 but it's not actually honoring
that either so I'm not really sure why
what we could do is like after so many
iterations you could you could have it
like let go and put the print the arms
XYZ coordinates yeah yeah you can print
those out you can get the arms position
it's still rise enough
so we definitely can't make it a gold
based agent if we can't even get it to
reliably hit the puck we gotta solve the
actual physical issue that we're having
right now before you gonna bother with
anything else I think
yeah the arm is very stubborn so we have
the puck X and so let me go back over
here
I forget what the the method is to get
the arms position
things like get position maybe you're
something
yeah get position so we could just print
out the get position every time
no the z-axis is 1% up and down so X is
forward and back Y is left and right in
Z is up and down
I wonder if maybe surely like pass and
all the another time out there so we can
at least we know for sure that setting
the acceleration sometimes is causing us
issue
I can't answer a question better armed
for learning the do bot or you arm I
couldn't tell you it looks like the well
first of all there let's see
I guess it depends on what you're trying
to do with it probably
to find the XYZ to be relative to the
camera I'm not really sure what you're
asking the the camera just has so many
pixels like once we pick the region of
interest and then we're just moving the
wine in a normalized percentage so the
arm has its own act like y axes and it's
not the same as the camera
so I thought about using tensorflow
object detection and maybe that could be
doable but I'm pretty sure that would be
slower than just filtering color and an
image so I thought changing the
acceleration would be happy but
immediate freeze
and it definitely lifted up your stand
summer reset
[Music]
yes let me try to change desired arm why
was round it to two decimal places like
I can't imagine why passing long
decimals would cause a problem but who
knows
yeah
I also don't know why that keeps
happening other than if like the cameras
not transmitting data for some reason
we need some way to like get it out of
the corners when it gets stuck in the
corners
sorry I can't scroll that chat
yeah my chat just totally timed out
interesting whoa dad again
hmm
I'm also why isn't the arm against a
back wall
why would you want the arm against the
back wall so the arm actually is like
bolt down points this so you could bolt
it down to like something so because
sometimes the arm like it'll hit the
wall there's something like that and
it'll actually like push the arm so you
could like bolt it down so wouldn't move
itself around I just didn't really want
to do that until I was done figuring out
other things maybe I'm hacker is mining
Bitcoin that's probably
I need some way to automatically reset
this puck that's what we really need
what's going on here guys nothing
nothing to see here
so you can put I don't know where it is
here it is you can put like this little
camera on like the front of the of the
arm so you can get like a first-person
view perspective on the arm but
increased fames if I could I would
put a live mouse on the puck it seems
like a good one
GTA project stopped just development got
too slow we're still out we saw plans to
continue the GTA project but it just I
don't know if Daniels still here but it
blamed in basically that's what I would
say
yeah I'm still here but I can't really
talk with you asked
I can't hear something's on this Court
and I have big blog and when I'm talking
I'm hearing myself after about the
second so I can focus on talking to you
basically yeah we're in the process of
developing some trainer applications
that will gather data for training
neural networks both so for driving
trolls and object detection Charles but
it takes time a lot and attitude to
develop that we had a lot of problems on
TAS I like develop some mod game modes
that we all want to grab that we need
it's almost done we being as from now
current part has to be developed his
most vital and I actually had to take my
headphones out and to be able to say
that why wouldn't you just mute the
stream
yes same over time place the bug with a
mouse pinion read my deal might be like
and that was because I was trying to
sync with you but there is a delay and
so I'm gonna sure why it's not striking
here
so yeah the arm at least right now just
follows that y-coordinate rather than
attempting to predict anywhere where the
puck is going so there's a few issues
one one is we can't really trust this
current frame rate it's not really a
static you know let's say 15 or 20 or
whatever you would hope it to be frames
per second so you can't really you could
use like blur motion blur or something
like that to detect the speed but I'm
not really sure how reliable that would
wind up being I think we just lost sure
did the arm I think the arms is legit
drop the Stryker and moved up I'm not
sure why it would do that it's just it's
decided I think it's done anyway yeah if
you knew the trajectory of the puck sure
you could definitely that would be
better also just being able to actually
strike the puck and actually aim for
hitting it into the goal would be ideal
as well but again just like the other
things the first problem we have to
solve right now is why does the arm
freeze up and then how can we get it to
even hit the puck hard enough without
setting the acceleration up to these
astronomical numbers it's not even
hitting the puck hard enough to make it
to the other side so until you have that
solutions there's not much point in
doing like trajectory and all that kind
of stuff
wireframe so choppy well at least right
now we've got this you know 0.2 fifth of
a second sleep just trying to slow
things down because that seemed to be
causing trouble when it was coming in
possibly too fast we'd tried to try that
it's also like it's definitely aimed up
for like the arm is too high now I
almost wonder if when the arm slips if
it actually never fixes itself because
now it's like way above I mean I'm
surprised it's even holding on to the
thing right now
so the numbers are already being rounded
to two decimal places so even though
like they're not being rounded in here
before like I'm passing anything to the
arm obviously this is a whole number and
then here I'm rounding it to two decimal
places I mean I could we could pass a
whole number but I'm not really sure
that's actually gonna do it
I'm honestly just I don't think it's
necessarily the high frame rate because
even when we were sleeping for a fifth
of a second so we're really just issuing
five frames a second it was still
freezing up so I don't really think that
could be the issue
no I don't think you can cancel any
commands that are sent to the arm all
you can do is do a flush command which
only just waits for all the commands to
finish
yeah we'd be definitely cool to get to
arms play against each other but not if
they can't hit the puck to each other if
they can't make it to each other that's
a pretty boring game but yeah that would
be the goal if I could get two arms
playing against each other I just can't
seem to solve why it why it gets stuck
why do you think changing this since
swing would change anything because
that's all all that scan all that does
is like let it take another swing at the
puck I'm not really sure that's going to
help
[Music]
auto focus
actually I don't think the cameras set
to auto focus right now oh it is it
could be possible because it would it
would definitely trigger an autofocus
when when I went over there I like the
shadow came into play that's possible so
I just turned off auto focus on want to
be pretty shocked if that's what's
causing that but I I wish we could
figure it out
also the arm has just raised up even as
I reset this script from running it just
keeps the arm is not going to the
initial spot so part of me wants to just
like unplug and replug back in the arm
I think I'm just gonna do that because
even when I set it back to the exact
same Z coordinates it's over the striper
now I don't know why it's doing that
why do you use Python 3.7 died
I have Python 3.7 but I'm not using I
thought 3.7 here so it's still a Python
3 6
so that's crazy so right now that just
closed oh no I just stayed at that level
never mind again
he's definitely timing out at this point
which is a problem and again I never had
it time out there when when I was just
using it without this other camera so it
still makes me think that it's a
bandwidth thing
how about an AI that play csgo yeah I've
thought about doing that especially with
the object detection I think it could be
pretty easy I don't really know all the
rules with the problem with like a lot
of online games is that if you do stuff
like that you get a lot of trouble I
know you can you can at least play it
like on your own machine but what I'd
want to be able to do is like play
against other people and I don't know if
there's a way for me to do that in csgo
or not without getting like a a band
yeah I actually started playing see it
like I played I started training a model
in csgo like against bots in just like a
look you can just make a game and say
how many bots you want and all that so
it's actually a really conducive to
training something especially because
you can just keep issuing commands like
right there
but how easily can you make a server
like do you have to like rent servers
with csgo or can you host it like on
your own
so probably like csgo so the other
problem is csgo is and like any
first-person shooter is you have to like
playing against other players would be
really hard because the enemy is like
generally you need to be able to see
somebody and take a shot at somebody
when they're like it's just a tiny
handful of pixels rather than like Babak
detect them when they're you know in the
game let's say like 10 feet away that's
really easy to do when they're like
really close but any map that would be
like an outdoors map or something like
that would just be to impossible I think
this arms playing this game pretty
consistently I forget what our last
changed even once
I really wanted to make a rinse game
play AI would be really easy but that's
a perfect example of an example where
you get banned that would be
unacceptable
I thought trying to think I think I
think they ruled at one point like
mechanical playing it was like a I saw
reddit thread someone used like I think
it was a fan to like click the mouse and
the question was whether or not that's
like cabana boys is not really so much
software based but you'd still have
software running it but they were
claiming that the since the fan was all
mechanical and there was like no
quote-unquote software even though I'm
pretty sure software runs but I'm not
really sure so you can definitely train
the bots to detect body parts but you
need a large image to do it like you
could never detect a like because in a
first-person shooter you have to be able
to detect like a person from a huge
distance like that's part of the skill
that's involved is like determining is
that a bush or a person but that's gonna
be pretty hard in a with an AI at least
with all the object detection or just a
simple like continent or whatever
so his starcraft2 I actually tried to
mess around with that and I couldn't
figure it out I have it like I have
everything set up or at least I had I
don't know it's probably doesn't run now
since I've upgraded tensorflow and all
that but I couldn't figure that project
out and it was like maybe a couple weeks
after I bought paid for Starcraft they
released it for free that was great so
so an aimbot is I mean it would be an
aimbot but generally aimbots don't work
by detecting pixels on your school it's
not really how they're how they're
working for you
but I don't know if anybody remembers
the like I made an aimbot for in GTA
that was like see if I can't pull that
one up okay this is the first time the
arm has died in this entire session
a rebar
now it's dead again I wonder how far I
have to scroll to find that video of our
Terminator
here it is yes so this one just used
object detection and when it found the
person it would just go to the center of
the coordinates and then shoot so it was
pretty good at like a real close
distance but even here see how long it
takes to finally detect the person like
once it detects the person the reaction
time is you know perfect but definitely
it can take a while that's pretty good
[Music]
loud let's see probably because I had
desktop audio on as well and the
subwoofer probably picks up a lot
no that wasn't yellow that was I think
that was Coco all the greatest names for
these things
can we watch a video of you watching a
video of one of your videos no although
here
if I did this
it's even better
no I've never coded like I've never even
used yellow I mean it'd be worth trying
if I was gonna go do another like aimbot
kind of thing but I've never actually
used it
I mean object detection was pretty quick
I mean but we definitely needed like
with the Python places Grand Theft Auto
series like it really needed its own GPU
so I mean it could go it could work at
maybe 20 frames a second but it needed
the I think I I think I ran it on the
Titan and then the self-driving car was
on that on the actual 1080 TI I'm not
sure you actually need a Titan to run it
at 20 frames a second with grand theft
auto but you need something decent for
sure
but maybe if I can't get the arm to to
stop freezing and or not move at super
slow speeds I just was expecting to be
able to get make of a real life aim by I
probably not it's probably not a good
idea I did think about using the arm so
the arm has the the laser on it and I
thought about you could use the arm to
like shoot mosquitoes at your at your
home that is close to a real life aimbot
as I would get Titan V you would
definitely work but it's like way too
expensive of a card for what you get
so we could definitely I'm try to think
to like cuz you've got I don't think you
can make so we could definitely make our
own servers in csgo and then so if I
make a local server in csgo could can
you make that publicly accessible for
anybody
I'm sure be able to play it especially
if back is turned off I'm pretty sure
people would just come in and use
aimbots against the the bots that's my
best guess as far as how that would go
ha it was going so good so I wanna be so
will it be a csgo aimbot I don't think
that's I think you'd want to stress that
it's not like it's MIT I guess a visual
based aimbot or something like that and
also it would have it would also
navigate the map it would be a csgo bot
or a csgo AI or something I can't do pub
G although with pub Gianna you can make
your own custom games I wonder how they
would how they would take people making
a bot playing pub G although I'm sure
they want press anybody playing pub G
yes so that was my goal bench was to
have two two BOTS competing against
themselves and then you can make each
bot kind of explore using different
parameters and stuff like that and then
the victor becomes the new training
model and then you just continue
repeating that process over and over and
over and over
[Music]
I will not stop asking you heard of
Intel movi this only like briefly I
don't know that much about it you want
to tell us about about it
with the a iso-ne like vanilla by I mean
the it's kind of like the same thing
like people would come into this the
self-driving car GTA stream and be like
this doesn't drive even as good as the
you know like how did the AIS in Grand
Theft Auto Drive well they have access
to to the game engine data like they're
not driving visually they're driving
rule-based when they're being fed
exactly the coordinates and all that
stuff to turn and where to go and that's
the same thing with like the game bots
let's say in csgo they they have access
to all the data they're just made to be
kind of stupid but you you could if you
just had direct access to like all of
the game data you could make a like a
bot that would just be undefeatable or
at least super difficult
electric airsoft airsoft turrets
it really wants to just go into that
corner
on your web page there are 28 single
line HTML tags without ending well I
never claimed to be an HTML expert
why not using it
the Mobius
I don't know send me an example of what
you think I should use from them crypto
quail it's already there so if you go to
github.com / centex / you arm there is
there's both just like a simple image of
the table and then there's also like an
output i don't know if i can view it no
I got it downloaded so but you can
download that file and you can see it
anyway that's a video so you could use
that
what do you mean what do you mean the
video didn't work because like reading
in the video though I mean like the only
difference is you're like you won't have
a WoW one well even then I'm pretty sure
you can since you can just iterate over
it but you're just gonna iterate over
the frames no different than what we're
doing like here
the alternative to using cameras I'm not
sure how what else you would use
I'm not really sure if it's the camera
feed that's getting stuck or if it's
like the arm itself that's getting stuck
we really do need them to be on like
separate processes and then we could
figure out which process is getting
stuck
I blame Daniel he was supposed to be
doing that focus on making Westworld
the GTA self driving by like what kind
of computer was on or what
convert if you want to see the code just
go to the github page for it
this
yeah this is a it's a standing desk it's
like a it's an adjustable desk but I
actually always pretty much leave it on
the same exact setting I don't really
change it unless I'm gonna eat or
something like that the best sometimes
I'll sit at it but other than that I
just need it where it is
every time I adjust the puck it seems to
freeze
now it's definitely like adjusted over
the
a tutorial about building a gaming PC
I'm pretty sure I actually have one on
my channel used if you go to like really
old playlists from probably like 3 or 4
years ago you might find it is basically
the same
I'm not sure it was the best tutorial in
the world but got the point across it's
pretty easy anyway as long as you make
sure everything is compatible with
itself it's pretty like I'm not sure how
you could ever plug anything in
incorrectly like every plug is very
specific I'm not sure where you could
make a mistake to be honest
yeah I probably do more live streams in
the future I'm not sure how much longer
I'm gonna have this one cooks I just
can't figure out how to solve this this
arm I wish it wouldn't freeze and I wish
I could get it to go faster and I wish
the PUC wouldn't get stuck there
everybody
so yeah you definitely I get a bunch of
the Nance but that shouldn't cause any
trouble so if you go look at the code
itself like we're not passing any Nan's
to the arm
the only time we pass like a movement to
the arm is when we have enough red
pixels to work with so that really
shouldn't be causing any trouble bad
servos perhaps I mean probably not I
feel like if someone from you factory
came here and saw what I was doing with
it they would probably say it's not the
servo it's the fact that we're speeding
everything way too way too much so like
the arm itself is moving too quickly for
sure so the speed here at 20,000 is
acceptable by them they say I think they
recommend the max speed of like 30,000
well this is a million and so as always
so probably that would be the first
thing that they would you would want to
change like the servos really aren't
necessarily meant to go that fast but in
my defense they in there they have like
a promotional video for the arm and they
were playing air hockey like on their
phones like with a phone app to like
move the arm around and that's what gave
me the idea to try doing that myself and
I can't get the arm to move as fast and
so so I feel like there's got to be a
way
I just don't know it
yeah you could use a Raspberry Pi you
I'm not sure you couldn't filter
everything through the Raspberry Pi
though like doing open CV at a high
frame rate on a Raspberry Pi alone would
be not cool you probably only want the
PI to control the servos or something
and the arm keeps lifting up - that's
annoying
I mean that seems to me move yeah I
think you can see it I mean that's
moving at a decent rate even though I
moved it down to 20,000 rather than like
a million or whatever I chose there
so at least in this case it's definitely
as soon as removing it the same man as
same amount of speed actually
this is the the blurring window here
so Robbie the commands are definitely
getting processed and in time first of
all like every every loop we flushed so
we're waiting for the commands to
actually complete but then also
everything's getting slowed down so
there really shouldn't be any like
overflow of commands
but also after changing the speed to
50,000 I haven't really noticed that the
arm itself is moving at any different
speed so I'm kind of actually I think
I'm gonna drop this to 30 it seems like
the acceleration makes all the
difference I'll leave that at 20 such
this is just the arm setting up
but so the arm is also like still lifted
up over the puck or the striker a little
bit which is pretty problematic
this one's definitely slower
you should get a like a long dowel or
something then I can poke the puck
hmm yeah that's super slow at least for
the strike we got to get the arm to go
quicker
it just doesn't hit it hard enough let's
just painfully slow
train your dog spoke puck this good
ideas guy
so really it's just this move that we
really want to be as fast as possible
I totally just moved the puck and then
it got stuck immediately awesome
I'm not sure why it's not striking the
puck at this point
and now it's over the puck hmm I'm
pretty sure it's supposed to be a tea
interesting so our arms actually a
little more so let's change this to like
70
Wow
maybe if it scores
oh thank you Jason I made a Linux
version of your self-driving car project
using a simple car racing game on a boon
- do you have any videos of it
so Robbie you can definitely you can you
can give it relative positions so you
can calculate like from where the arm is
to where it's going or like where you
want it to go and then you can give it
like a relative motion that you're
hoping it would make but I think when I
did that like I tried doing that as well
and that didn't really seem to help it
help it either sorry I want to see what
this is get position timed out mmm
we can at least stop printing that out
there's probably no reason to be
printing that every time
hmm
see like now the arm is just timing out
at time and I'm not really sure why
it looks like a got Mario Cart
any reason he used Alec's net over the
inception model the inception model was
like way that you it would run a lot
quicker and then also the model itself
is just much much smaller I'm not sure
if you made it that far in the GTA
series but we eventually we switched it
to the inception model and that
definitely helped a lot
also for some reason in the GTA thing
like running it on different machines
despite having like identical hardware
it was separate like it would act
totally different the only thing that
there was like Windows 7 versus Windows
10 that was it but that made a big
difference
am I being lifted up or is the desk
going down we'll never know
I really need this USB cord him to make
it to this other spot Daniel wants me to
try plugging in two different because
they're plugged in basically next to
each other you better try that
the camera got reset oh my god you're
killing me
see
find the puck Oh
I can't tell I think it just went over
the puck at that time
hmm okay it finally did freeze that
again you know they're in different
ports really don't know what else to try
to get to stop from freezing like that
but if I'm going to need two computers
for two competing arms that's gonna be
really expensive endeavor it would be
nice if there was a reset procedure but
no whiz I'm not even sure I would do it
right now cuz I'm using the gripper
yeah
hey that was actually a score might be
the first score in the lifetime of a bot
yeah I mean if you tell the arm directly
where to go I mean it it moves pretty
well I mean depending on how much well
how fast you ask it to move like if you
ask him to go slow it's like it's really
precise but if you if you want it to go
fast that s where it starts getting
problematic
oh that was a good one too they two
scores in almost no time just a couple
minutes apart
incredible
get a taller puck probably the taller
puck is it's gonna weigh more and then
it's going to probably get stuck in the
middle of the thing we're often like
something slide as well
what do I do for a living this
Oh ruff
where's the puckett 80 and we said
strike and above 70 is it in a shadow
man no am I missing the strikes oh it
definitely was striking they're not sure
what's going on there all right
I think it's lunch time for for myself
I'm getting hungry we'll have to figure
out this issue on another day and maybe
probably put these on separate processes
and then we can figure out which ones
going wrong I'm pretty confident the arm
I've never had open CB lock up on me
like that but we'll see
my food is waiting on me so probably
either next time we can work on this or
maybe maybe we'll poke around with
object detection on csgo or something
like that
look like alright guys until next time